all right wren
yo wren where'd you grow up where are
you from i'm from middle port kentucky
and tell me about your uh your childhood
you had both your parents when you were
a kid
when i was childhood when i was and i
was the
son of daybreak and uh
my mother was geraldine bray we just
spoke to you
yeah from hell in kentucky here in the
middle fork
right and tell me about your uh your
childhood how how would you describe
each other
when i was back in my childhood i rolled
up as a little boy i always liked to
build my little go-kart that little
wheels and stuff
and uh i get on these little county
roads with dirt roads back then and
we we rolled up down on them and i like
little german shepherd puppy dogs
i made them it was real interesting they
stayed right with me
every which way i'd go they'd go with me
yeah you have appalachia you grew up
here yeah i grew up in
appalachian and you you chose to stay
here not leave no yeah i choose to stay
here and
i always want to work in life so that's
what i've done i made a work around
myself what kind of stuff have you done
for work
i worked uh i worked in coal mines i
worked in coal mines for about 17 years
i've done a lot of work in the coal
mines done a lot of work around the coal
mines
inside and outside both uh
i've done all kinds of work in life in
my childhood life i
had grown uh you know i was a garden my
daddy showed me how to
work the gardens so uh i work gardens a
lot so that made me a farmer kind of
like a farmer and what much farming
going on here but
the kind of farming we done you try to
make a little money on it you know
back in them days so we growing up to
make money
that's what it was all about when it's
14 15.
i mean poverty is is almost like every
every household
has to deal with yeah it was bad back in
them days i mean nobody had money around
you
so the only way you could get it was get
out and work in these hills and
and may you know make this it was
illegal stuff here and you can make
money off of it
illegal stuff yeah the little english
stuff pot yeah marijuana pot
yeah we growed it and made a little
money you know that kept us going year
to year there wasn't no way to make it
there was nothing here in these
mountains these appalachian mounds there
was nothing
here but just and and that's how we made
it
we grilled a little pot and sold it out
of here and made us a little money and
kept us going should legalize it a long
time ago
yeah but still it's still illegal today
yeah it's still illegal today yeah but
still yeah people food ready a little
bit not much as it used to did but
just a little make a little money along
so something in life
yeah and drugs are a big deal here yeah
drugs are big deal yeah crystal methods
come in
and uh yeah it's no good that stuff is
and the pills are uh the
painkillers have been around for for a
couple decades right
yes that stuff's been around a long time
it's not real good for people when
people's
kids stuff like that you know we don't
allow that around here
we think the reason the reason so many
people go to drugs is because of how
because there's nothing to do there's
nothing here about drugs
pretty pretty percentage is 95 drugs
you're
and a lot of people's own those drugs
because there's nothing else to do
you know you have no no gym nations no
more
for people that play ball or or play any
kind of sports it's all wet dead
um pretty much your drugs just took over
yeah have you had any uh
prison time or jail time because of
drugs no i never was in prison for drugs
in my life
never was never been never been in jail
for drugs
and do you have kids of your own oh yeah
i got two fine boys
jonathan blake bray and josh bray how
are they doing oh they're doing great
got one of them a school teacher you
know teachers to school and
got the other one works for the state of
the state
worse for the state that's great good
for you
which for how much money do you live on
a year now
uh yearly i live on about a thousand
dollars a month i live on about 12 14
000
a year really i just dry eye dryer just
to come
you know just to what the commonwealth
gives me just
it's about hour drive what was your
favorite thing about living in
appalachia
my favorite thing living in appalachia
is real quiet back in here and
i can breed my dogs and and just turn my
dogs loose and let them go wild these
mountains these creeks and
it's about the happiest place ever been
in my life it's beautiful here yeah and
it's beautiful it's quiet
and everybody's friendly here what
people ain't on drugs
they're real friendly and real good to
you they're real good people in
in leslie and clay and harlan
do you ever wonder what your life would
have been like if you had been born in a
big city like atlanta
oh one time i left here one time i left
here about
1990 uh i was about 18 years old 17 and
i
i took off went to dallas texas down in
the big city
one time in my life never been there
before in my life went down there one
time and
boy i had fun stay three months down
there and the first thing i've done i
met a black guy
and i never thought i'd ever get talked
to black people like this
gave me a job and took good care of me
down dallas
and i stayed there three and a half
months and try to pray back to the hills
couldn't stay had to come back had to
come back to the appalachians
so now i got now to read those dogs and
and i breed labs and i
and the name of my dogs appalachian
labrador retrievers
and i love raising dogs so do you
consider yourself a hillbilly
yeah i'm a hillbilly yeah i'm a kentucky
hillbilly and you're proud of it
proud of it yeah how do you define a
hillbilly what is the hillbilly
hillbilly's uh people that ask you about
swing on grapevines and these mountains
and climb trees like toys and and have
fun
and in the mountains these mountains you
don't have to take nothing in the
mountains to have fun they're
sturdy they're free big roots and all
kinds of stuff we dig roots cohouse
black cohouse for the
like the engines used to back the old
days to
cure people sickness we dig gin sing
we're big bad at it when we go
so this is ginseng that you uh okay yeah
this is we're back on appalachian
mountains
on uh on the ginseng me and my dogs and
my brothers and us
we all go in these hills and we we dig
we dig
this ginseng to send over to china
across the water so
so the china people could have good
things to eat like these big four prongs
like stuff like this right here
they love it over here and it's it's not
like
anywhere else you go you won't find big
roots out of the mountains of leslie
county
uh like this it's the ginseng quality is
real high it's like two thousand a pound
over in china
what do you guys sell it for and over
here they rob us and take it from us we
get only about uh
400 a pound for it over here in kentucky
but you know we should get more in that
but we poor and you know we just we let
them have it
what makes us happy we got it right here
forever and ever and ever
it's right there for us and we get to
get it and then send it out to them
that's what we love to do babe these
hills
we love it yeah here here in the
mountains
of leslie county the gin saying is it's
real
strong it's got the juicing is strong
the appalachians is the the
slack marijuana the marijuana is better
here in the appalachian mountains like
ginseng is
that's why everybody wants it fur
because it's better
we always grow the best we always have
the best i guess
if you got the best you know you just
all you want to do is have all the
wrists
does it pronounce appalachia or
appalachia appalachia
appalachia appalachia yeah okay here i
hear different from different people but
yeah yeah well some people call
appalachian you know it's a big
appalachian see i got the mine i got the
dogs you know appalachian labrador
retrievers
and i got all the dogs that i raised
today for them i got
about nine female dogs and four males
and i breed them just just in these
mountains you gotta have something to do
so i breed these dogs and
take them ginseng and women and stuff
and in the mountains it's real fun to do
that
appalachia has kind of been left behind
the rest of the world the technology has
moved
advanced very far forward but here
you're kind of still there's no cell
service here and there's there's
no sales service these mountains very
very certain places you get sales
service
it's not like to see it yeah very basic
like grocery stores or
really just gas stations with like
grocery stores here
you have to spend 20 dollars 25 to get
out here to get to one
to get your food so if you just want a
pipe or a cake or something like that
it's gonna cost you twenty dollars to
just get out to get that cake here in
these appalachian mountains it's a long
ways in out of here
uh time to get back up here to us to see
us uh you've got a lot of money
do you feel out of place when you go to
a big city yeah for our place yeah it's
it's a lot of difference
uh you're more free back up in here like
it's a free world of free land
you're more free up here in the
mountains than you are out in in the
cities
you got all those people in the city
around you up in there back in here you
don't have that
all you got bacon ears like all the
mountains and the mountain bears
we have the black bears here yeah you
have bears you have elk you have deer
you have coyotes you have
yeah we have all the cows and and and we
have
our squirrels and ducks we got all kinds
of animals here in the mountains yeah
your mom was telling me you guys uh
we got flying squirrels we got
we got coons we got we got the skunks
and you eat a lot of these animals we
eat a lot of these animals yeah the [ __ ]
you can eat the [ __ ] it's real good
uh you can eat the uh the groundhogs a
lot of people with your groundhogs
uh the ducks you eat iom uh
you there's all kinds of animals in the
mountains that you can eat
a lot of people just eat that black bear
they'll kill it date it you can eat beer
yeah they ate barriers too yeah elk they
failed
yeah interesting so a lot of characters
out here a lot of people get in trouble
with the the
law and yeah a lot a lot of liars here
has been going on for the last five
ten years uh going on in here a lot of
like outlaw
personalities right yeah a lot of
personalities the confederate flag to a
lot of people means
means uh like ra it's it's symbolic of
racism but out here the
confederate flag means something very
different right you were very dead it
means like
you're an outlaw yeah yeah we were the
rebel flag guys or being arrested
there's nothing to do with racism
no it has nothing to do with racism no
we don't
just uh with the black people uh when i
wear the rebel flag uh
for the last 20 years i never thought
about one time that it even concerned a
black person
right and back in my voice i think
that's a big misunderstanding people see
the confederate flag and they think oh
that means you're a racist
yeah that's wrong no it doesn't the
black people should understand that
immediately that's wrong
absolutely uh we wear blue blue uh
it's for black that's why i got black
blue on today is
a lot of people wear blue like i do
today because it's for the black boys
but i'm not princesses i wear all colors
and you're working federer flag
red white and blue you'd wear a
confederate flag right now and be proud
of it be proud of it yes you will i got
one that i got one to wear yeah
yeah i got one i always waited ever
since i've ever been 16 year old
i've had that flag on my head and more
every day ever since and i wear it from
now on
and then no no whatsoever race them
against no black people
never everybody say i'm
i'm nationwide everybody likes me
because i'm nationwide everybody calls
me nationwide
i know everybody i know how all kid i am
to all kinds of people around here
you know everybody in the county yeah
just about everybody in the county oh i
know i'm national i know everybody all
over the states
in other states i know a lot of people i
really i get to know a lot of people i'm
anti-social
but i ain't i'm social with everybody
they say well you're anti-social no you
know you're sociable
everybody so that makes me one
nationwide i like to know everybody and
good to everybody
i want respect like i give respect um
if you give respect you'll get respect
if you're good to people
good will come back to you seven
my granny told me seven times more
greater come to you
when you're good to people yeah ryan
thank you so
much thank you so much for talking with
me yeah you're fascinating
yeah i like your top s'mores i know a
lot i'm nationwide
i know a lot i can sit and tell you and
uh i know some real good stories that
tell us true
all right we'll come back next time you
come back give me on the next one
and put me on youtube again they love me
there
all right thank you very much thank you
so much